On last March 24, Reuters said that the head of the Professional Syndicate in Lebanon, "Arif Yassin"
received a catastrophic news from France Bank of Lebanon that
the bank had closed accounts worth $20 million belonging to
the syndicate, and issued a check for one-fifth of the nominal value of these accounts
Those $20 million were collected from engineers' subscriptions
over the years and were dedicated to health care and pensions
covered by the Syndicate for about 100,000 engineers in Lebanon
This catastrophic scene is the new normal in Lebanon now and over the past few weeks
Banks close the depositors’ accounts. So, the amount of money they have painstakingly and diligently saved over the years
is just lost and up the spout in front of their eyes
Consequently, thousands of depositors have filed cases to courts
hoping to get any available amount of money in the banking system
Banks, on the other hand, are anticipating events and closing accounts
in widespread financial collapse that the country is witnessing
Foreign courts are now ruling in favor of their own national depositors
The first ruling in Britain was issued on March 1, when the High Court
of Justice in London ruled in favor of a British businessman named Vatche Manoukian
to oblige Bank Audi and Societe Generale Bank in Lebanon
to pay back $4 million of his seized money in that broken banking system
due to the capital restrictions imposed since the beginning of this financial collapse in 2019
The matter is not the same for Lebanese depositors, so to speak,
most of the Lebanese depositors, especially the small ones
are not able to get their money back. Meanwhile, the Depositors Union,
which was established to recover people’s money, consisting of lawyers and activists,
has filed more than 300 lawsuits against Lebanese banks since 2019 on behalf of the depositors
however, the union was able to recover the money for 12 lawsuits only
In view of this very serious situation, there are accusations of the ruling elite in Lebanon
that they are protecting the wealthy and banks linked to senior politicians
According to Reuters, informed sources say that the banks are transferring money to politicians and their allies
In short, the wealthy, politicians and those with influence in Lebanon are
the only ones who are able to transfer their money which
sources and methods of collecting remain questionable by the way
As for the owners of small accounts, we are to set eyes on what might happen to them in such a case
All of this highlights crucial questions:
What will be happening if the bank I am dealing with goes bankrupt?
As a depositor, will I be losing my money in whatever country it is deposited?
What happens to the troubled bank itself?
Will it be foreclosed or sold, or something else?
This is what we are going to figure out together in today's episode.
Don't forget to subscribe to the channel to see all our episodes.
I am Ashraf Ibrahim and this is the Economic Informant
This episode is sponsored by Babil Games, who have an exciting game called The General,
a military strategy game that simulates the present and uses modern warfield technology
It has more than 100 modern weapons systems designed in a distinctive way, such as ballistic missile submarines,
attack helicopters, stealth fighters, parachute units, and many more.
It has a system for forming alliances between players.. The game is free,
you will find it on the Google Play Store and the Apple App Store, and you will find links in the video description.
Download it now and you will get 13,000 piece of gold and a full month subscription to the Security Council for free. This offer is for one month only.
Banks are an influential and vital part of the modern-day economy
They provide various banking services to the general public,
issue loans and create liquidity in markets. Moreover, they
provide other financial services such as currency exchange and certificates of safe deposits...etc.
In short, banks are the safest places to keep money in today's world with all its risks and complexities.
But these same banks may be in real trouble if there are problems in the economy of their countries.
The extent of its predicament varies according to how profound are the problems and crises that its country's economy is going through.
This situation may result in one or more banks going bankrupt.
A serious problem related to the lot of depositors' money rises here.
This is the question that concerns everyone, without exception, when a bank goes bankrupt
As for savings accounts, certificates, and all other forms of depositing
which customer or depositor adopt, what will their status be in this case?
So, before you question the current situation of the bank you are dealing with;
let me first highlight when exactly a bank goes bankrupt and how?
When you go to a bank to deposit money, or else, when some money is transferred to your account:
the bank keeps a very small part of this money and the rest is invested.
Banks in this case are more like a recruitment company
On one hand, it takes your money and invests it; on the other hand you get an interest in exchange for it.
So, what is the amount of money that the banks must keep, roughly?
The entity that determines this ratio, which is called the “Reserve Requirement”, is the central bank of the state
Its authority is to oversee the commercial banking system
within its country through supervisory and regulatory powers.
What is meant by ‘Reserve Requirement’?
It is a percentage of the total funds of depositors in banks,
whether they are in local or foreign currencies,
a percentage that every commercial bank must keep in an
account with the Central Bank without any interest or fees from the Central Bank in return.
One of the main goals of reserve requirements is to prevent a bank
from ceasing to function if unexpected large mass withdrawals occur.
For example, if we look at Egyptian banks, we will find that the Central Bank of Egypt
imposed a reserve requirement ratio of 14% on each bank,
this ratio was 10% until October 2017 but the Central Bank raised it to 14% now.
For example, if I deposited 100,000 L.E by tomorrow at any bank in Egypt;
this bank must hold 14,000 pounds of the total sum in its account at the Egyptian Central Bank
According to the statistical bulletin of the Central Bank issued last February,
the total deposits of the banking sector in Egypt, by the end of December for the year 2021,
amounted to 6.4 trillion pounds which means that 14% of that
sum is commercial bank's reserve at Egypt's Central Bank.
Of course, this ratio differs from one country to another.
There are countries that do not require a reserve for commercial banks at all,
such as Canada, the United Kingdom and New Zealand.
Hence, how does the bank deal with the rest of that sum of money?
Of course, banks do not save it in their vaults. they would rather
invest it so that you can pay back the deposits interests and make some profits.
The simplest form of investment is to provide loans to customers,
whether they are individuals, companies, or the government itself.
There are other, more complex investment methods, such as
buying shares in the stock exchange, buying certain assets such as lands and real estate,
or acquiring certain profitable projects, and other different forms of investment.
Banks here, like any investor, are subject to loss when
the economic situation is distressed or the economy is experiencing exact difficulties.
Therefore a bank’s investments can be lost and a calamity breaks out.
When a bank realizes losses, it will be unable to fulfill its obligations towards its depositors and creditors.
It consequently cannot neither provide cash to depositors, nor commit to its obligations to creditors.
Hence, the value of its assets falls below the market value of its obligations.
For example, if the sum of deposits in a bank reaches 10 billion dollars
and the bank loses large sums of money in some investments.
Its assets will be decreased as a result down to 5-7 billion dollars.
Here the bank will declare bankruptcy. It is possible for banks to go bankrupt due to
financial chaos and economic collapse accompanied by high levels of corruption,
as the situation in Lebanon currently, wherein banks are looting depositors’ money.
Coming to another more important question: What happens when
bankruptcy occurs and the bank liabilities are greater than its assets?
The biggest problem of a bank at such a time is that
the depositors get to know that the bank is insolvent and is no longer able to pay them.
In this case, the bank probably borrows from other banks
which is in their interest to keep the insolvent bank steadfast.
Questioning why? Because as soon as depositors get to know that the bank is insolvent,
a bank-run would take place wherein clients would be withdrawing their money.
If this happened, it would be a disaster. Bank panic will arise and
people will run to banks to withdraw their deposits, including
those banks that are in sound condition even . This will reduce
the liquidity of the insolvent bank more than it is.
So, the insolvent bank will be forced to stop the withdrawals or
set limits by allowing the withdrawal of only small amounts.
People's main concern in such a case is to know what is going to happen to their money in that bank.
Will they be able to get it back or not?
A model of significance in the United States can be taken into consideration before discussing the destiny of depositors’ money in banks that can go bankrupt in some Arab countries.
Let's go back to the twenties of the last century, to the beginning of the Great Depression,
many banks were bankrupting on a daily basis in the US.
depositors lost their money and there was no way to recover it back.
Can you imagine that a third of American banks declared bankruptcy at that time!
From 1929 to 1933, a total of 10,000 American banks had declared bankruptcy.
American depositors' money had been gone forever.
They lost 140 billion dollars in this short period due to bank failure.
This led to depositors running to all banks to withdraw their deposits at the same time,
there was not enough money in vaults because banks invest most of the money they get as aforementioned.
In the midst of this financial collapse, US President Franklin Roosevelt signed the Banking Act,
known as the Glass-Steagall Act of 1933, to establish the Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation, known for short, FDIC.
The mission of this institution at the time was to restore the confidence
of panicked Americans in the banking sector in the wake of this financial collapse,
thus the institution would serve as a bulwark against bank panic in the future.
So, what is the Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation job?
It protects customers’ deposits in the cases of bankruptcy or failure of any of
the commercial banks insured only by the institution (the insurance is optional for the banks)
There are banks that do not want to be insured. By the way,
if you are in the United States, you must make sure that the bank in which you are depositing your money
is insured by the FDIC, otherwise your savings will be in greater danger than if you put them in an insured bank.
Regarding the insurance of the depositors’ money; a point of significance pops up here:
the Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation does not return all deposits if
the bank falters or fails as it covers a maximum of 250 thousand
dollars per account in each single bank. To make it clear; if someone
opened a bank account; and deposited 350 thousand dollars;
the maximum sum of money that person would get back if the bank falters or fails is only 250 thousand.
As for the remaining 100,000, you will wait for
the liquidation of the bank’s assets or the sale of the entire bank.
Then, they may be / may be NOT able to get the money back.
Some details worth mentioning at this stance; you can process your accounts
to be fully insured with more than 250 thousand dollars.
For example, distributing your savings to different banks in case the sum is more than 250,000 $
because the insurance limits include each single bank.
Otherwise, you can open specific accounts (not individual accounts), such as a joint account
in which there is a beneficiary; or certain types of accounts Like retirement accounts.
Some people may think that it is unlikely that a bank is going bankrupt in America now;
as the last crystal clear bankruptcies were during the global financial crisis in 2008 -2009.
Not true! In the last 15 years, almost every year, banks falter and fail in the US, except for 2018 and 2021.
The number is much less than the days of the financial crisis of course
but there are still faltering banks and the Deposit Insurance Corporation undertaking their settlement.
If we look at the last five years, we will see that in 2017, eight
American banks failed with total assets of about 6.5 billion dollars.
In 2018, no banks failed. Yet in 2019, four banks failed
with a total assets of 214 million dollars. In 2020,
four banks failed with total assets of 458 million dollars
among which is the Almena State Bank in Kansas, which stumbled on October 23, 2020.
Since then no other banks have stumbled in the United States.
Here in the Middle East, there are central banks that guarantee depositors’ money, either fully or partially.
However, there are other central banks that do not offer this type of insurance
Yet, even if the central bank of your country, whatever it is, does not insure deposits;
as it works carefully not to expose the depositors sums of money to risk from the early beginning.
Any central bank uses its supervisory and regulatory powers to ensure the member banks
do not engage in any activity that could be unstable or put depositors' money at risk.
Well, let's suppose that a bank for any reason is bankrupt.
What is the fate of that one that goes bankrupt? What is its eventuality?
The central bank is often the institution specialized with settling troubled banks.
Nonetheless, the US Federal Reserve is not responsible for this issue in the US.
As I said before, the Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation
is the one that takes charge of matters for any bankrupt bank.
So, the first thing the Central Bank or this Deposit Insurance Corporation
does is to contract with another bank or rent another sound bank with sound management
and let it take over the office of the failed or faltering bank until
it is sold or until its assets go into liquidation if there is no buyer
The new bank that manages this troubled bank temporarily is called ‘bridge bank’
It takes over all the assets and liabilities of the troubled one and begins to administer it again.
The goal of the bridge bank is to make a restart to this failed bank with its available capabilities
It calms the creditors and depositors down; thus avoiding
a bank panic that could lead to the other banks to fall.
That is why its role at such a time is excessively critical and vital
in order to save the economy and prevent a financial collapse.
After the bridge bank begins managing the troubled bank,
It takes time until any entity shows up to take over this failed bank.
Sometimes the bridge bank is the one who takes it over. Other times this failed bank is merged with another bank.
But, if none of this happened as no one may be courged to take over that troubled bank
a single option is left for the Central Bank to settle the troubled bank:
which is liquidating its assets.
First, an Asset Valuation Review takes place,
a process in which the value of the troubled bank’s assets is assessed.
Thus the appropriate price that the Central Bank or the Deposit Insurance
Corporation will accept to sell the assets at is determined.
These assets could be the loans that the faltering bank had at the beginning,
the depositors’ liquid money that was left in the vaults, lands, properties, and others.
After reviewing the assessment of the assets, the sale will be done.
The profit hence is hoped to be distributed between depositors and creditors according to certain accounts and ratios.
Back to Lebanon, unfortunately the situation there is unmanageable.
In a shocking report issued a few months ago the World Bank shed light on the ruling class in Lebanon
that caused the Lebanese economy to fall into one of the worst economic depression
crises in the world because of their exploitative grip on resources.
It is still the elite abusing its position even though Lebanon is suffering from one of
the major 3 financial collapses that occurred in the world in the last 170 years.
Can you believe it? Yes, One of the biggest three financial collapses in the last two centuries.
Merely a month ago, the Lebanese judiciary freezed the assets of 5 major Lebanese banks
along with their board member directors due to suspicions of corruption as transactions took place
among them and the Central Bank of Lebanon.
A few days later, the Lebanese Public Prosecutor was seeking to freeze
the assets of the President of the Central Bank of Lebanon Riad Salameh and his partners
in Swiss, French and Belgian German and Luxembourg banks,
due to accusations related to Salameh’s embezzlement of
$330 million of Lebanese public funds with the help of his brother
Last but not least, may all the Lebanese be safe, God willing. Hoping this crisis comes to an end as soon as possible,
getting their money back with the Lebanese economy returning stronger than the first.
In the end, do you think that Lebanese scenario can be seen elsewhere?
I will follow all your answers in the comments. Don't forget to download the game from the link below or through the QR code; you will like it.
I hope you like the episode, like, share, and above all; tell your friends about us, they may like it too, Goodbye.